[Musique]
quand les humains apparaissent sur
cette terre
le premier accueil est un combat mortel
pour la survie
[Musique]
les hommes doivent lutter contre
forces de la nature contre les bêtes ed
même entre pères et fils depuis la bagarre
continue dans chaque club puis comme
ça se passe chez les animaux
le mâle le plus fort gagne et devient
chef de tribu les femelles s'offrent à lui
engendrer une autre progéniture
résistant et quiconque s'y oppose est tué
sans pitié est la loi naturelle de
Plus fort
avec une différence tandis que les animaux
soumis aux lois de la nature
les hommes au contraire aspirent à
leur plier ces mêmes lois
avantage
mais la loi du plus fort est difficile à
apprivoiser les hommes forts sont encore faits
plus fort avec les armes et les anciens
les textes du monde entier sont un
répertoire des massacres
[Musique]
la vie n'a pas de valeur pendant des millénaires
jusqu'au jour en Grèce
la démocratie est née
[Musique]
ce régime politique rejette l'idée de
un homme gouvernant les citoyens
ils expriment leur opinion avec le vote est
l'homme fort est remplacé par moi
représentants de la majorité
[Musique]
est encore un système imparfait parce que
la majorité décide à sa guise
désavantage de la minorité qui n'est pas
d'accord mais la démocratie est un bien
pas vers la justice
tout change avec les guerres sanglantes
La démocratie recule entre Athènes et Sparte
et la loi du plus fort
revient s'établir entraîné pour la guerre
les Grecs humanisent les îles et les côtes
de la Méditerranée mais ils sont précoces
battu par les Macédoniens d'Alexandre le Grand
arrivant jusqu'en Inde le
les montagnes d'afghanistan vivent encore
les kaffirs les descendants des militaires de
alessandro est resté en Extrême-Orient
[Musique]
après les Macédoniens sont les Romains un
devenir les champions de la loi du plus
fort subjuguer l'europe le maghreb
et au Moyen-Orient
formant le plus célèbre empire des
histoire
[Musique]
les romains arrivent aussi en chine via
un trafic régulier de navires entre rome et
canton où il y a encore quelques
pièces d'or et d'argent de l'époque qui
va d'Auguste à Trajan
c'est l'empereur Néron qui ouvre le célèbre
route de la soie sur cette via roma
exporter vers l'asie
l'alphabet le verre le sablier les raisins
les parfums et les pierres précieuses de
Baltique et Méditerranée
[Musique]
sur ce même via roma à porta la
soie
[Musique]
le thé chinois le papier
l'encre
la poudre à canon le fer forgé
perles de porcelaine
le jeu de cartes aux échecs et
même des spaghettis
si les Romains sont victorieux avec des armes
dans la vie civile ils ont des problèmes
les différents coups des peuples sont sévères
les soumis causent des malentendus e
violence parce que tout le monde veut imposer la
propre foi, puis de ramener sa
soumis à l'ordre de l'empereur
Constantin décide que l'empire doit
avoir une seule religion indiquant
héritiers c tous les cultes sauf le
Christianisme Constantin définit
d'accord avec le pape Sylvestre et oui
nomination à la tête de l'église chrétienne
centralisation du pouvoir politique e
spirituel sur une seule personne
l'empereur romain
[Musique]
l'empire romain est si vaste qu'il a
divisé en deux un empereur et l'ouest
et un empereur d'Orient
[Musique]
la pax romana règne depuis deux siècles
en venant des steppes d'Asie
central
les huns d'attila mis au fer e
feu
peuples germaniques d'europe du nord
ils fuient alors en masse et entrent
dans l'Empire romain d'Occident
pillé une plongée en passant
cela favorise la rébellion de
Les troupes allemandes levées
dans l'armée romaine ils déposent
l'empereur romain d'Occident e
saccage du centre religieux de Rome
de l'empire c'est le chaos
les barbares triomphent
Rome, cependant, n'a pas l'intention
renoncer à sa suprématie a
puissance militaire perdue mais tient
encore le pouvoir spirituel est un pouvoir
si fort que Clovis roi des Francs
renie le paganisme et s'agenouille
devant san remigio pour se faire
baptiser chrétien
cette conversion fait de clovis le
titre d'empereur romain d'Occident
aussi le roi franc charlemagne le grand
vainqueur de l'Europe s'agenouille
devant le pape à couronner
Empereur romain
[Musique]
la peur de dieu rend les papes comme ça
puissants qui couronnent les gouvernants
participer aux gouvernements et peut
communiquer
c'est la loi du plus fort mentalement
cependant un problème inattendu surgit
quand la plupart des gens
Les Européens devenus chrétiens rejettent
violence
suivre la parole du Christ
certains sont martyrisés à la place
que d'enrôler et de tuer des ennemis
cela inquiète les souverains européens
constamment à la recherche de soldats pour
leurs guerres font donc appel au pape
urban ii pour trouver une solution
puis sous prétexte de m'expulser
les sarrasins de jérusalem urbain ii inspirent
les croisades et le cri de dieu le veut
justifie la guerre
les érudits de l'église expliquent que pour
bonne raison bio permet le meurtre ed
les moines templiers me tuent alors
Sarrasins pour rendre service à
christ cette versité au
les musulmans
remontent à plus de trois siècles parce qu'ils ont
occupé la péninsule ibérique
proximité de cette religion
Rome rivale et guerrière agitée
qu'il couronne ensuite empereur du sacré
empire germanique le roi le plus puissant de
allemagne premier bouton oui
lui aussi s'agenouille devant la bavure
jurant sa protection à l'église
Rome s'affranchit enfin de la proximité
musulman avec la reconquête de la
une espagne et un portugal très catholiques
leurs grands voyages en mer commencent
divisant l'Amérique du Sud où
ils massacrent les indigènes qui volent les leurs
or les français c'est aussi un peuple
européen très puissant avec des colonies
en asie en afrique et dans les amériques
leur général révolutionnaire Napoléon
bonaparte conquiert l'europe
entier en supprimant l'empire sacré
La Rome romaine germanique n'a pas le temps de
se plaindre de perdre le sien
empereur napoléon chasseur de
nobles et prêtres est fasciné
de la couronne impériale
[Musique]
il s'agenouille aussi ou presque de
devant le pape qui le couronne empereur
des Français en toute pompe
de la Rome antique
les Britanniques, en revanche, n'acceptent pas le pape
de rome sont chrétiens et beaucoup d'anglicans
inventeurs boursiers riches et puissants et
de l'industrie colonisent l'asie
afrique australie d'amérique de
nord exterminant chez les indigènes
[Musique]
même les allemands sont très puissants ils ont
l'Europe occupée au VIe siècle
supprimant les vrais les celtes et les
Les Bretons sont devenus les ancêtres
des peuples européens d'aujourd'hui
les français descendent des allemands
francs anglais d'ang lee allemands
les Espagnols des Allemands Wisigoths
Italiens des Allemands lombards
suédois des allemands vikings et ainsi de
suivant
sur la patrie des Allemands son i
Les Allemands ont fait peur au monde
entier
pendant la dernière guerre mondiale
l'europe est un véritable berceau de
les pays puissants exercent la loi de
les plus forts depuis trois mille ans et s'arment
toujours même en temps de paix parce que le
l'histoire enseigne qu'il est plus sûr d'être
redouté appelé ainsi avec cynisme
politicien de niccolo machiavel beaucoup
apprécié par les gouverneurs modernes
la loi du plus fort déstabilise à nouveau
le monde
personne n'est à l'abri malgré le
propre pouvoir de dissuasion
L'Europe doit être sur ses gardes car je
pays d'autres continents n'utilisant pas
la soumettre avec les armes qu'ils ont déplacées
conflit économique
les états-unis font partie de ces pays
dans le passé terre de possessions indiennes
puis une colonie anglaise peuplée de migrants
Européens et esclaves africains
la colonie anglaise se rebelle en grand nombre
Grande-Bretagne et proclame la république de
États-Unis
la rébellion est financée à certains
nobles anglais ambitieux
rétablir l'empire aristocratique
perdu en europe le transformant en
empire financier aux états-unis
pendant les guerres mondiales
l'empire financier des etats unis
prospère grâce à la production d'armes
qui vendent à tous les alliés et ennemis
surchargeant ceux qui ne le font pas
dévaluer est la loi du plus riche avec
que les états-unis offrent leur aide
économique du plan marshall aux pays
ravagée par les guerres à condition que
héberger des bases militaires américaines e
cela en fait le premier pouvoir
militaire de la planète
puis ils forment l'ONU et nés pour
intervenir militairement dans
différences entre les différents pays
achevant ainsi leur vérification de la
monde mais les 800 bases militaires et les leurs
des armes de plus en plus sophistiquées aggravent
l'économie des États-Unis qui
ils impriment ensuite des dollars au-delà
leur disponibilité en or
emprunt à la chine japon e
des paradis fiscaux
[Musique]
le dollar américain et la devise plus
utilisé dans le monde mais est comparé
à la livre sterling au franc français
au deutsche mark aux monnaies d'Asie
d'Amérique latine et d'Afrique
ces monnaies sont un danger pour
états-unis et embellir alors je
pays riches d'amérique latine e
asie moyen-orient et afrique
étouffer son économie
en europe les etats unis sont plus
prudent ils n'utilisent pas d'armes mais oui
d'accord secrètement avec l'Allemagne pour
enchaîner les pays européens
dans l'union européenne une organisation
supranational dont les dirigeants
ils obéissent aux ordres des états
uni
cela permet à l'allemagne de fonder
l'euro face au mark allemand et de
s'enrichir aux dépens des autres pays
membres du syndicat à qui il impose la
conditions difficiles de la troïka
une institution et gérée par
Commission européenne par la banque centrale
Union européenne et Fonds monétaire
international
un autre adversaire de l'europe et du
russie plus grand pays de la planète la
la russie est née d'un avant-poste viking
kiev et subit pendant trois siècles
l'invasion musulmane des Mongols
tartres lorsque les tartres quittent le
prince chrétien orthodoxe de moscou
ivan le terrible annexe les territoires
voisins et se proclame tsar de tous
rousse avec le titre romain de césar le
le titre de césar ne suffit pas pour
Pierre le Grand considère alla
la russie comme troisième rome succédant
Byzance se proclame alors empereur
Romain sans passer eut le pape de
rome qui n'est pas reconnu par
chrétiens orthodoxes
l'empire russe devient riche et puissant et
cela ne convient pas à l'allemagne e
du financement des États-Unis puis
la révolution des bals et des rites de lénine
l'empereur de russie abdique et lenin
établit la dictature communiste
[Musique]
le communisme est un régime politique qui
prône une société sans classes en est
déclarer que la production est suffisante pour
besoins de la communauté et de la
la propriété est abolie
[Musique]
mais des millions d'opposants ils sont
exécuté dans un nouvel élan
formes de la russie communiste impérialiste
l'union soviétique subjugue les pays
d'Europe de l'Est
installer intelligemment des missiles nucléaires ed
envahit et la somalie et l'afghanistan de
mais ses dépenses militaires sont insoutenables
est l'effondrement de l'union soviétique et avec le
reconstruction de la perestroïka et glasnost
transparence la russie tourne la page e
restaure l'indépendance des pays subjugués
cependant la russie en a un gros
regret ukraine ukraine en
passé était une région russe et ses
capital etf et patrie historique
de la russie voulait l'indépendance
[Musique]
puis dans le but secret de
réapprovisionner la russie arme je
sécessionnistes les dégâts
avoue ses larmes à un référendum
controversé
mais la crise ukrainienne n'est pas la bienvenue
des États-Unis et de l'Union européenne
imposer des sanctions à la Russie
l'économie toujours en vigueur
[Musique]
la russie est aussi un grand état
tampon entre l'europe et la chine communiste
et avec son milliard et demi de
habitants est le futur adversaire de la
le monde entier
le président chinois l'a même pris
élu à vie et aspire à remplacer le
les états-unis contrôlent le monde
puis à nous et à remodeler
les équilibres planétaires en planifiant
aussi la dissolution de l'union
L'Europe est devenue trop dépendante de
Chinois
le premier pays à quitter l'union
L'Union européenne et le Royaume-Uni en tant qu'alliés proches
des États-Unis et d'autres pays membres
ils envisagent leur sortie du syndicat
Europe et zone euro
cette dissolution conviendrait
la russie fait un clin d'oeil aux petits
pays européens prêts à les ingérer si
ils deviennent orphelins
[Musique]
à rome les papes n'ont plus d'empereurs
être couronné à partir du 16ème siècle
Les gouvernements européens se sont débarrassés de la
le clergé et les royaumes sont devenus laïcs
sont devenus constitutionnels ou
républiques démocratiques et politique
il a remplacé la religion
[Musique]
les électeurs sont les nouveaux croyants je
les parlements sont des basiliques je
les partis politiques remplacent
les talk-shows des congrégations religieuses sont
des sermons et des isoloirs sont
les nouveaux confessionnaux
combien l'empire romain s'est transformé
dans l'église catholique en gardant le
propre hégémonie sur plus d'un milliard
de fidèles
[Musique]
sa ville rome est bien assortie
Florence
à Venise
aux seigneuries de la Renaissance qui
dans l'art rivalisait d'inculturation tout
cela s'arrête brutalement 1861 fut le
naissance du royaume d'Italie
les Piémontais financés par le Royaume-Uni
ils attaquent les états sans avertissement
Italiens et admettre la péninsule italienne
à cette époque la patronne de l'état
France pontificale et très catholique
à son second empire mais perd la guerre
contre l'Allemagne naissante et a repris
son statut de république laïque
Le pape Pie IX excommunie le roi piémontais
mais sans l'aide de la France, il ne peut
empêcher son invasion
les Piémontais dévastent le sud
de l'Italie
les patriotes sont appelés des brigands
tiré sur les rives du royaume des deux
les siciles sont dépréciées et la sicile est
laissé à lui-même
face à la confusion les nobles
Les siciliens se forment alors
une organisation secrète la mafia
dirigé par des hommes d'honneur la mafia alla
mission de rétablir l'ordre dans
sicile sicile négligée par l'état
Italien même pendant la dernière guerre
monde de ce profiter de la
les états-unis cherchent une place sur la défense
où débarquer leurs troupes
ils demandent donc la permission à la mafia
le faire en Sicile sans trop de prise de tête
en retour, ils offrent beaucoup d'argent pour les sièges
le futur gouvernement italien et le
installations aux états-unis est
une offre que vous ne pouvez pas refuser
la mafia accepte et les fascistes sont
anéantie mais la nouvelle génération de
mafiosi ébloui par le pouvoir politique
plonge dans le crime organisé
se tordant comme les tentacules d'un
poulpe la nouvelle mafia s'enrichit avec
les travaux publics et privés imposent une
pourcentage aux entrepreneurs et tue
sans pitié
les opposants les informateurs et les leurs
des familles
[Musique]
c'est la loi du plus cruel
les soldats et juges italiens qui
ils découvrent la négociation secrète entre les
la mafia et les institutions sont massacrées
la guerre entre la Sicile et l'état
Italien
une guerre qui se termine lorsque la mafia
forme son propre parti politique
apparence est un parti de droite mais entre
dans les coulisses avec tout cet argent illégal
et à recycler
la mafia corrompt tellement tout le monde que son
correspondre
remporte les élections italiennes
[Applaudissements]
mais le patron de la fête est un homme de choses
amoral que les grands de la terre
indigné l'oblige à disparaître al
plus tôt de la scène politique
la fin est justifiable mais les moyens
d'occasion c'est un vrai coup
un revirement politique immédiat
obtenu sans la volonté populaire de
cette faiblesse politique et ils ne profitent pas non plus
certains économistes italiens
et après avoir empêché l'Italie de revenir
quand ils votent, ils s'installent au gouvernement e
vendre les meilleures entreprises italiennes un
faveur des institutions financières qui
gérer la troïka quand l'italie
retourner voter
les populistes qui accusent la classe
politique d'avoir pillé le pays
ils gagnent les élections italiennes
le système de communication est nouveau
parce qu'il propose la démocratie
participation assistée par internet
à la place de la démocratie actuelle
lecture représentative je
représentants de la démocratie populaire
participatif permet à l'individu
citoyen à participer personnellement
à la vie politique donnant son propre
alerte instantanée
c'est un événement extraordinaire un autre
grand pas pour l'homme
jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité un
l'individu a pu s'exprimer
point de vue sur le monde entier
laissant des traces indélébiles
cette opportunité n'était réservée
aux grands de la terre hammurabi le roi de
Babylone a fait traduire son code en
toutes les langues connues pour que
a été élu dans tout son empire
mais pas dans le monde entier et ne pouvait pas
même pas interagir avec ceux qui le lisent
aujourd'hui c'est possible c'est assez
ordinateur ou téléphone portable pour se connecter
directement des particuliers
très loin l'un de l'autre
transmettre en temps réel ce que
ça se passe dans tous les coins de la terre est
aussi une bonne occasion pour
connaître les intérêts des autres
parce que ce monde interdépendant est
toujours mieux d'être informé
[Musique]
on peut donc affirmer que pour le
moment où internet favorise le meilleur
des démocraties possibles en temps de
paix
temps de guerre comme au temps d'athènes
de Sparte la loi du plus fort revient
donc
malheureux le faible
[Musique]